jim fait un beau bonjour benoît apparu
au genre vous portez un certain nombre
de positions iconoclastes au sein de
votre parti républicain on se souvient
que vous étiez prononcé pour le mariage
pour tous en 2012
plus récemment vous êtes opposé à
l'annulation du concert de black m
à verdun se souvient aussi et vous
l'avez dit vous ne réclamez pas
l'annulation la fermeture des fans zone
pour l'euro est ce que finalement c'est
ça être juppéiste c'est prendre le
contre-pied de la direction du parti des
sarkozystes sur sur plusieurs sujets et
du pays s'il ya ce qu'on pense c'est
dans la majorité c'est dans la minorité
du parti peu importe on dit ce qu'on
pense et on arrête peut-être de calculer
en permanence les choses à mon électorat
pense que donc la majorité du parti
pensent que donc je suis non le rôle
d'un politique crée plutôt d'essayer de
guider les choses et de dire ce qu'il
pense qu'il a au plus profond de
lui-même et de dire simplement sa vérité
ça plaît tant mieux s'appeler pas
j'allais vous dire quelque part est pas
suffisamment de liberté de paroles sont
du parti ce n'est pas une question de
liberté par ouaga souvent c'est pas le
parti qui est en cause en l'occurrence
on a une totale liberté de part de
parole sous la direction de nicolas
sarkozy ça pose aucun problème en la
matière c'est souvent les calculs que
nous faisons les uns et les autres en se
disant je reste dans la ligne où je me
cale par rapport à cette ligne en pour
rencontre d'ailleurs elle a certains qui
sont fait une spécialité du contre par
principe nous c'est pas la question
qu'on se pose question qu'on se pose
c'est c'est juste c'est pas juste on
veut on veut pas en arbitrant fonctionne
pas alors peut-être
autre divergence que black m je vous
rappelle que
la position d'alain juppé n'était pas
tout à fait la même autre divergence que
vous avez peut-être avec certains de vos
camarades vous vous l'avez dit vous ne
réclamez pas le retrait de la loi
travail en 95
alain juppé avait fini par retirer le la
céder face à la rue sur la question des
retraites
est-ce qu'il avait eu tort oui je pense
que nous avions eu tort même si ça
devenait intenable en 95 n'était pas
suffisamment au fait des choses il
fallait tenir effectivement je pense
qu'il faut de tenir savez quelque part
mon raisonnement
ça va vous paraître bizarre mais black m
l'ol comme ris et qui finalement quelque
part un peu le même pas bon je pense
qu'il ne fallait pas inviter black m
pour les commémorations de 14 18 mais
une fois qu on l'invite on tient bon et
on n'annule pas l'autorité deux manches
les mails qui remettent en cause sapé
les droits d'inscription ça s'appelle
quelque part oui doha lancé va te
rappelles droit dans son autorité de
l'état
là encore la loi elle conneries on l'a
évoqué telle heure c'est un texte qui me
paraît pas suffisamment allé assez loin
donc je le voterai pas est ce que pour
autant il faut le remettre en cause
sous prétexte que 50 casseurs 300
casseurs veulent le retrait de ce texte
de loi
réponse non parce que sinon c'est donner
raison aux casseurs et ça ça ne me
paraît tout en restant dans son trait à
la loire à nos pratiques donc alain
juppé n'aurait pas dû céder la rue à 495
il ne cèdera pas à la rue si jamais il
est élu en 2017 et qu'une contestation
sociale massive se développe contre par
exemple ces ordonnances pour le code du
travail
heureusement soit 95 95 on a le même
problème
si on veut être sincère que le problème
de françois hollande
la campagne électorale de jacques chirac
est une campagne centrée sur ce qu'on
appelle à la fracture fresque sociale
on n'a pas vraiment annoncé pendant
cette campagne électorale qu'on allait
réformer les retraites
réformer les régimes spéciaux réformés
l'assurance maladie et serrer la vis
budgétaire c'est pas du tout l'angle de
la campagne électorale quand vous faites
une campagne là et que vous gouvernez là
ça ne marche pas et si vous perdez votre
légitimité à agir
vous devez cd malheureusement est donc
tout l'enjeu pour 2010 et de ckoi
annoncé la couleur c'est d'être précis
d'annoncer la couleur avant de façon
détaillée et chiffrée quantifier quitte
à dire des choses qui font mal quitte à
dire des choses qui ne plaisent pas si
derrière on veut avoir la légitimité de
le faire vous pensez que ça suffirait à
empêcher une manifestation jeudi la
colère sociale
je sais pas si ça suffit à empêcher la
méditation de colère sociale mais deux
remarques si vous ne voulez bien la
première c'est que le sous-entendu de ce
type de réflexion c'est quoi donc on ne
fait rien il ya un risque de manif
il ya un risque de blocage il ya un
risque de grève donc on ne fait rien
c'est pas ma conception de la vie
politique sinon je vais faire un autre
métier mais je vais pas commencer à me
dire tiens je réforme ça parce que c'est
pas trop dangereux ça c'est dangereux
j'y touche pas parce qu'un risque de
grave sinon on fait plus rien bons
premiers éléments le deuxième élément
moi j'ai la perception le sentiment que
si effectivement on a la légitimité
populaire pour agir la légitimité des
urnes
on pourra agir y compris face au blocage
alain juppé va recevoir 1 nathalie
kosciusko morizet aujourd'hui à bordeaux
ils vont se voir cet après-mdi éditons
dîner même se voir ensemble est-ce qu'il
faut y voir les prémices d'un
rapprochement
il faut y voir que cette primaire c'est
une compétition pas un combat et si
demain nicolas sarkozy françois fillon
bruno le maire qui vous voulez viennent
à bordeaux ou ailleurs
bien évidemment que les uns et les
autres se rencontrera franchement nous
sommes dans le même parti
nous avons vocation au lendemain
novembre à travailler ensemble pour
préparer la présidentielle et à
gouverner ensemble
on n'est pas elle doit pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de sa candidature doit
pouvoir se présenter c'est important
selon vous mais c'est important d'avoir
une crème dans le dispositif de la
primaire bien sûr c'est important mais
tout fait au moins trois candidates à
partir du moment où comme tout le monde
est là les parrainages si elle n'a pas
les parrainages malheureux ne pourra pas
être qu il n'y a pas de raison d'aidés
qui qu on n'est pas là pour se donner se
refiler mamaï est entre guillemets sur
n'est sûre d'elle et des parrainages
qu'il nous dit donc que chacun
effectivement arrive à récupérer ses
parrainages saldana question dernière
question emmanuel macron lens ce
week-end sa grande marche est son
opération de porte à porte en vue d'une
hypothétique candidature pourquoi pas
est ce que ce sera un challenge au
sérieux
et peut-être dangereux pour alain juppé
pourquoi partir parce qu'ils peuvent
partager ensemble de politiques communes
jusqu'à 3,6 les candidats représentera
quand même plutôt la gauche mais a
priori nous ne représenterons quand même
plutôt l'agresser dans le corps mais le
rite ou est ce que justement il n'y a
pas fait avant qu emmanuel macron soit
candidat avec son président ancien je
pense que de l'eau va couler sous les
ponts
il faut d'abord si je comprends bien que
françois l'on n'y aille pas donc c'est
vrai qu'un président de la république
sortant n'a y pas la présidentielle pas
femme quand même très que le premier
ministre n'at il pas pour que finalement
le troisième larron entre guillemets
avec le soutien du ps puisse y aller
tous apparaît comme très fin très très
hypothétique